c'est un médecin de campagne comme on en
trouve dans bien des régions du québec
louis duc est à 69 ans et pratique à
saint patrice de beaurivage depuis 1979
comme bien d'autres médecins de sa
génération il part bientôt à la retraite
mais il ne trouve personne pour le
remplacer
mois il suit plusieurs patients depuis
des décennies comme jocelyn camiré
hélas couru jocelyn en 1995 lors de
l'accident de travail qu'il a paralysé
il soigne plusieurs générations de la
même famille mais grand parent il était
avec zorro village
massaï 16 enfants avec la retraite du
docteur duquette plusieurs d'entre eux
risque de se retrouver sans médecin
3000 patients pourraient devenir
orphelins à la coopérative de santé du
sud de lotbinière parce qu'ici le
docteur duquette n'est pas seul à
vouloir prendre sa retraite
claire nantel à 69 ans et pratique elle
aussi ici depuis 1979 elle veut aussi
prendre sa retraite
docteur nantel encore 1500 patients mais
faute de relève elle ne peut garantir à
cette jeune maman qu'un médecin va
pouvoir la suivre
mais toi tu as à pau une nouvelle
qu'elle doit annoncer à tous ces
patients ou à chaque patient qui dit que
ce que je vois faire docteur qu'est ce
que je vais faire de ta livre m'a trouvé
un médecin ben vous ça me prend aux car
c'est sûr que ça rentre
notre
marche vers la retraite difficile
et nice dans la salle d'à côté même
scénario
pas de garantie pour kelly et grégoire
simard qui est pourtant sur le point
d'accoucher
j'ai des gens qui viennent à mon bureau
qui nous est doué mais - louis de thunes
connaître 40 ans tu me laisses europe
allemagne
s'est déchiré
déchirent
dans la région le départ des deux
médecins suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude
les gens viennent ici en clinique
qu'est ce que je vais faire c'est une
médecin oui vous allez pouvoir venir
mais on a présentement les caps et en a
deux qui partent les sans rendez vous en
plein ça va déborder le départ de ces
médecins angers qui suivent beaucoup de
patients est un problème partout au
québec en 2010 745 médecins ont pris
leur retraite au québec un nombre qui
est passé à 2 175 l'an dernier le
problème préoccupe le collège des
médecins du québec qui souhaite que les
médecins apprennent à déléguer plus de
tâches aux autres professions et
travailler avec d'autres d'autres la
santé de façon prochain tim
pendant leurs cours de médecine ils sont
pas taxables mis en situation
d'interdisciplinarité oui mais à mon
avis c'est là qu'il faut travailler plus
que de chercher à former un plus grand
nombre de médecins il ya passé tacot
pulmonaire docteur duquette travaille
déjà avec l'infirmière linda blondeau il
souhaiterait en avoir deux autres mais
là aussi c'est la pénurie
il n'y a pas de solution facile surtout
pas pour le docteur duquette déposer des
quotas aux jeunes médecins là on arrive
pas on faire
on transfère sur comme des chiffres
anonymes peu
faute en prime il faut tendre et 2500 ça
marche pas de médecin
il ya une relation qui s'établit
mais ici le temps presse faute de
médecins l'avenir de la clinique est
compromis autour de la fin avril l'année
prochaine ont voté
si on laisse la clinique telle qu'elle
est là éventuellement ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal